welcome to this video playing blitz
master from Hungary gila gila up yeah
there are many blitz masters and no one
is called the blood spatter maybe this
is a name to look into ok so the g3 set
up against this opening yeah I recently
have played that myself is white the Sun
Cueto came hmm yeah d5 leads to an
isolated pawn position not a problem but
something like that is going to play
with c3
my def 635 problem
if he goes if I if I can't play Knight
g4 probably fibers in the good news in
quencher we have that's quickly neato is
the movie 5 94 basically wins the porn
that sides useless ok some d5 now takes
Knight takes yeah this is some and no
one set up with rock do you wanna do is
this has been played recently I am by
micky adams i think against the jury
pool God and in the London classics last
year so recently is so yeah it's not
ages ago but also not yesterday okay
yeah I actually do like this position
from white to be honest it makes some a
very harmonious impression like Scott
them always this issue with the bishop
on nerds eh it's simply simply in
limited piece yeah how to how to develop
him mercy for of course threatened
yeah after c4s got Bishop f4 coming but
i Kenned I can't play Knight b6 mmm
Knight b6 Bishop f4 takes on CH mm okay
what I'd like to do is Bishop g7 to c6
this would pretty much solve all my
problems is playing that anyway okay
physics Bishop f4 I'm taking see form
yeah very interesting okay I need to get
Bishop c6 in yeah what's now we five or
not if I've looks very ugly but it's a
temple that bishops is sexier come on
it's the temple the alternative is
dropping the Queen vector c 8 allowing
Bishop t6 this is all so ugly and now i
get rid of this bishop my biggest
problem is this bishop and now i can
exchange it this guy is rated to 54 it's
a very very high rating in the in the
five-minute poor okay I mean the pool I
usually call it the pool not auto
pairing this is because I CC does call
it pool auto pairing something that
kingscrusher really coined this term
okay might be five film okay hmm
don't want to take this is some not too
great maybe night maybe Queen p.m. 96 26
e6 looks like it would square for the
Queen yeah if I 5 Kos did limit merely
limited this Bishop Wow 139 I'm really
down on the clock here that wasn't
really aware that i had spent so much
time I spent lots of time reham at the
first move already the good thing about
this queen is it's relatively secure
it's not so easy to take it don't
understand that really check IV for
tweener three the seafoam so I wonder
what this piece but I'm as i mentioned
down long time
Queen age 3 mm so let's see you is there
some way to immediately finish this page
for something
Queen g fool
intending night f form amongst others is
also Bishop d3 threatened if he goes
Quincy 6 the smoke th yeah worked yet
anyway right it's like these sex is just
too slow I can I can play them I can
play em what can i play Bishop g3
special g3 queen and Brooke turn tags
check
I can one this is amid I don't believe
that you can defend that check check
check things was chicken check time
warning check check check check check no
no the rock on age five no haha what the
heck Howard queen bee to everything
mates not this one queen bee to know
hahaha oh whatever show kind what a joke
no Queen 55 ah Oh God and rook t1 is
also just just a maid check check yeah
this is also made Queen D for everything
made I certainly i forgot the rook of
course yeah yeah Kim there are multiple
mates IAM dad was a very unclear
position when he blundered when he
blundered simply the piece and yeah okay
i just adjust blunder the queen with a
bit queasy five check in the position
where very very absolutely everything
winds probably that is even made yeah
even that is made everything mates here
no wonder we never taking with all
pieces i forgot i did see the rook so I
not much journalist it was only the
wrong result at the end okay thanks for
watching